this video is brought to you by
Squarespace Welcome to New York City
Concrete Jungle baked beans tomatoes
there's nothing you can't do except have
good weather
[Music]
New York City the land of all
possibilities if you're very rich Big
City Lights a kind of functional subway
system and apparently a lot of great
food over the next 24 hours I'll be
trying a bunch of New York City food
food that you guys recommended me we'll
try hot dogs Bagels pizza and a bunch of
other things and we're gonna give each
one of them a rating from zero to ten
because you guys love that for some
reason so the first food that we're
gonna try is a bagel bagels are a staple
New York City food so are you ready
oh I mean that looks stunning we're
looking at salmon cream cheese Capers
tomato and avocado on an everything
bagel toasted this is your half this is
my half get a good look at that
they care about the fillings here when
you eat a bagel it's gonna get messy I
don't want judgment for that the flavor
is there the fillings are there it's a
little bit messy to eat but this is
definitely super enjoyable for breakfast
The Bagel gets an eight from me let's
move on to the next food
check out this cinematic ass shot
so this next place we're gonna try is
called Joe's steam rice rolls it's been
recommended by you guys on Instagram I
don't know what it is I assume it's a
steamed rice rolls let's see turns out I
was correct in my assessment they were
in fact steamed the rice rolls thank you
do I add the sauce on top okay so I can
add these sauces on top this that looks
amazing so this looks like chili oil
Sweet sauce and then I think this is
like a sesame sesame sauce I'll do this
one I never had them before but I would
describe it as lighter and savory Mochi
this is one of my favorite textures it's
nice and subtle it's not too
overpowering this is amazing this is a
8.8
foreign
Gods the rain kept raining at an
accelerated pace which for some reason
made me want to eat something sweet so
our next stop was this place called
donut plant they had some crazy flavors
like Cacho a Pepe or Maple pancake but
they recommended these two the peanut
butter jam and then the creme brulee I
could not resist breaking that one apart
the donuts were nothing short of
delicious however I'm not the biggest
donut fan I do not want to disappoint
you but these were a seven to me but now
it was time to get back in that
wonderful rain it's
it's it's literally impossible
for us to even move I'm soaking wet my
shoes are filled with water my pants are
wet and cold I am wet and cold the rain
has won this battle but only momentarily
because later that night I was out for
pizza we're gonna hit up one of the most
famous spots for pizza it's called Joe's
Pizza being in there was very
intimidating they were definitely not
down to chat they just wanted to give me
the pizza and I get out of there and
that's it which I guess makes sense we
have a pepperoni slice and a mozzarella
slice first of all they're massive so
I'm gonna fold this this is how I prefer
to eat it
um there's juicy I don't know what else
to say it's really good pizza Mr Joe I
want to thank you for this pizza but Mr
Joe I thought it was a little overrated
I'm sorry but I can't go higher than a
7.5 later that night after one too many
drinks it finally stopped raining I'm
here in New York City and guess what I
don't need this I don't need this
anymore go away
it's not raining anymore I'm a little
bit tipsy
you know what the best food to have in
New York when you're tipsy is the only
right answer I decided now is a hot dog
and I decided that because we're gonna
go have a hot dog and I I need that for
the video to work there are a lot of hot
dog places in Times Square but this one
John's Famous it said there that it's
the world's best hot dog so that seems
pretty official to me what is like the
most Classic this is my first one
actually spicy
spicy that's all right man you can keep
the change thanks so much have a good
night this is my first ever hot dog in
New York
all right let me do that
oh
yeah
that guy was great I love that guy shout
out to that guy so there I was in rainy
Times Square surrounded by hundreds of
shiny advertisements eating a kind of
shitty hot dog for some reason the
uniqueness of that moment made me happy
and it's now a beautiful memory in my
brain objectively it's not great but in
the context of eating it in in Times
Square at 1 30 a.m in the morning it
hits the spot and I love it and it's
starting to rain again so I will rate
this up I'll give it a I'll give it a
seven look at that
we walked home in this amazing weather
but the next day we were ready for more
food welcome to day two first thing
we're gonna do today is get a pastrami
sandwich and you know this place is good
because there was a big line outside and
also inside the decor was very unique
and it felt like just an entire vibe
oh wow
oh look at that thank you thank you sir
we found the perfect place to eat
in the middle of a busy New York City
street we got two different types of
pickles I think this is this seems like
a fresher pickle
and now the main event oh boy I mean
look at that
that looks and smells
like heaven so we got this wonderful
juicy pastrami in the middle of just
plain rye bread mustard and apparently
that's the way to do it traditionally
nothing more nothing less
yeah
oh my God there is one of the best
things I've ever had in my life
um I want to kiss it I felt that deep
into my soul the way this is making me
feel I'm inclined to give this a pen I'm
giving this a 10 because I don't know
how I would improve this version of it
you got to take a bite of this okay our
next stop is a taco place it's called
the Los Tacos Numero Uno I guess number
one I've had tacos in LA and now we're
gonna have tacos in New York see which
one's better after spending some time in
the U.S tacos have quickly become my
favorite food in my opinion a perfect
food when it's executed correctly and
the way these tacos looked I was
expecting a lot I had a bite of the
carne asada and that blew me away but
then I wanted to try the al pastor which
is roasted thinly sliced pork with some
pineapple and that that was the best
taco bite I've had in my life Los Tacos
easily gets a 10 but how can we end this
on an even higher note well I'll tell
you a cookie so this is Apparently one
of the best chocolate chip cookies in
the
is the most famous and bestseller that
we offer okay if you've never tried our
cookies I highly recommend okay perfect
what a what a nice guy
I love that guy
oh boy I think this is the chocolate
Walnut
bro
[Music]
oh God
the way doesn't make him feel I don't
have to not give it a 10. it is the best
cookie I've ever had
has a 10. [ __ ] it if it makes me feel
like this it's a 10 but you know what's
even better than delicious cookies
today's sponsor Squarespace I love
Squarespace everyone loves Squarespace
Squarespace is the space to get a
beautiful and professional looking
website quickly and with literally no
coding experience they have hundreds of
customizable award-winning beautiful
templates that you can choose from
whether you're a photographer an
architect a food blogger or you just
want to sell your products and establish
your small business Squarespace has got
you covered with all the tools you will
ever need to run a website connect with
your audience and generate extra revenue
from gated members only content send
email Communications display posts from
your social media that's pretty cool and
you can go to squarespace.com right now
and just browse their templates you can
even make your own website and try that
as completely free they have a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
just go to squarespace.com Quark that's
my channel name and you can get 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain it's worth it guys trust me thank
you Squarespace for sponsoring this
video and on that note make sure to
click on one of these two videos
thank you for watching this is me in New
York
and
I'll see you soon probably back home